[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur France 24 un
débat consacré à la cop27 qui s'est
ouverte en Egypte à sharm-elcher alors
que l'ONU vous le savez tir une nouvelle
fois la sonnette d'alarme les promesses
des états mettent la planète sur une
trajectoire de réchauffement de
2,5°c à la fin du siècle et ça pourrait
être pire puisque les objectifs ne sont
toujours pas tenus selon l'organisation
inondations dévastatrice au Pakistan
sécheresse historique en Afrique de
l'Est cyclone en série en Afrique
australe dont à Madagascar les pays les
plus pauvres sont aussi les plus exposés
aux dérèglement climatique alors qu'ils
sont beaucoup moins émetteurs de gaz à
effet de serre que les pays riches
urgence climatiques dans un contexte de
très forte tension géopolitique entre
les États-Unis et la Chine et bien sûr
en pleine guerre en Ukraine 110 chefs
d'État et gouvernement s'exprime entre
aujourd'hui et demain c'était le cas
d'Emmanuel Macron cet après-midi alors
que peut-on attendre finalement de cette
COP 27 dans un tel contexte cette
conférence sera-t-elle utile face à
l'urgence climatique ou n'est-ce que du
greenwashing passera-t-on des promesses
aux actes qui va payer pour les dégâts
irréversibles causés par le
réchauffement dans les pays pauvres les
plus vulnérables et les moins émetteurs
et bien on va poser toutes ces questions
à mes invités j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à
mes côtés Brice Lalonde bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes président de équilibre des
énergies qui est une association qui
rassemble des entreprises engagées dans
la décarbonation de l'économie notamment
dans le secteur de l'énergie du bâtiment
et de la mobilité bienvenue à vous vous
êtes aussi ancien ministre de l'écologie
je tiens à le rappeler on s'amuse
français merci d'être avec nous en face
de vous et les trouver nous a rejoint un
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous députés
France insoumise de Seine-Saint-Denis
auteur de le bloc arc-en-ciel pour une
stratégie politique radicale et
inclusive et c'est aux éditions La
Découverte nous avons également avec
nous Jean Joseph Boileau bonsoir
economiste spécialiste des briques
membres du Cercle Cyclope cercle Cyclope
c'est un cercle d'experts sur
l'évolution des grands marchés et puis
co-auteur donc de Chine
diafrique
donc un livre sur la Chine l'Inde et
l'Afrique feront le monde de demain
directement en lien bien sûr avec notre
sujet nous avons notre envoyé spécial
qui sera là avec nous pendant tout ce
débat Marina Berthe qui sera donc avec
nous en duplex de Charmed cher en Égypte
bonsoir Marina
bonsoir
coopérer ou périr ce sont les mots
d'Antonio Guterres ce secrétaire général
des Nations unies la COP 27 s’ouvre
néanmoins sensi Jinping ni Joe Biden
d'ailleurs qu'il va s'y rendre le 11
novembre prochain après l'émetteur
Vladimir Poutine est absent les premiers
Miss Canadiens juste un Trudeau et
australien Anthony Albanais sont aussi
aux abonnés absents bref une COP qui
s'ouvre vous l'avez compris dans un
contexte géopolitique très tendu on fait
le point avec Ethan agit
acharmer le Cher le défilé des chefs
d'État et de gouvernement a commencé ils
sont une centaine des quatre coins du
globe réunis pour ce sommet de la cop27
pendant 2 jours les dirigeants se
succèdent à la tribune de cette
conférence climat afin de renouveler
publiquement leur engagement en faveur
du climat au premier rang desquels le
président Abdel fatal Sissi dont le pays
et l'autre de cette COP 27 qui dès sa
prise de parole a appelé les dirigeants
mondiaux à faire le bilan
avons-nous assumer nos responsabilités
en tant que chef d'État et de
gouvernement pour faire face aux défis
lié au changement climatique
est-ce que nos ambitions pour la
réalisation de ces objectifs sont à
notre portée
autant d'interrogations auxquelles les
dirigeants mondiaux vont devoir apporter
des réponses à l'heure où l'humanité
fait face à l'urgence climatique mais
déjà certains pays sont aux abonnés
absents comme la Chine les États-Unis
l'un d'où la Russie pourtant parmi les
plus pollueurs et ses absences n'ont pas
échappées ou secrétaire général de l'ONU
qui évoquent un suicide collectif si les
pays ne prennent pas de mesures rapides
contre le réchauffement de la planète
Antonio Guterres appel à un pack de
solidarité climatique
pour notre survie mais nous sommes en
train de perdre les émissions continuent
de croître les températures augmentent
et notre planète arrive à un point de
bascule qui fera du chaos climatique un
phénomène irréversible
européen et africains semblent prendre
la mesure de l'urgence et son bien
représentés à cette cop27 une trentaine
de leaders africains sur place venus
militer pour la mise en place du
mécanisme de perte et préjudice une
sorte d'assurance à laquelle
contribuerait les pays riches premier
contributeurs au réchauffement
climatique pour dédommager les états
sous-développés ils sont aujourd'hui les
plus impactés
Marina Marina verte donc à Charmed cher
pour France 24 Marina justement je veux
commencer par vous parce que vous êtes
sur place vous on voit que Biden
n'arrivera qu'après les résultats des
meeters
australien mais aussi canadien sont
absents on sait qu'il n'y aura pas non
plus d'accord formel à la suite de cette
COP en quoi est-elle utile
et bien c'est une COP c'est pas parce
qu'il n'y aura pas d'accord formel à
l'issue de cette COP qu'elle n'est pas
utile effectivement le mécanisme de
fonctionnement de l'accord de Paris qui
est le document sur lesquels les États
ont travaillé depuis la cop21 ça a pris
longtemps ça a pris beaucoup plus
longtemps que prévu et bien ça y est ça
a été bouclé l'an dernier donc
effectivement à cette coque il n'y aura
plus de négociations pendant des heures
toute la nuit sur un adverbe ou sur un
point virgule effectivement on est entré
dans une nouvelle phase des négociations
cette COP elle va être
utile déjà pour établir la communication
entre les pays du Nord et les pays du
Sud sur cette question on en parlait
dans le sujet à l'instant sur la
question des pertes et préjudice qui
doit payer la facture pour le
réchauffement climatique il y a c'est un
sujet de tension très clairement ici à
l'ouverture de la Coop et ça fait des
années que ça dure donc effectivement
cette coop elle va permettre et bien de
mettre ce sujet qui est jusqu'ici assez
et bien sur la table et puis
effectivement cette coop elle va
également permettre de remettre le sujet
en général du climat sur la table parce
que vous l'avez dit il y a la guerre en
Ukraine l'inflation la crise alimentaire
et puis la crise énergétique qui ont
relégué le climat après la crise du
covid 19 et bien loin loin dans les
préoccupations des dirigeants de ce
monde alors que la crise climatique très
clairement les scientifiques le disent
ici elle est en train de s'emballer ça
doit être une coque pour rien
je ne sais pas
ce qui me frappe moi c'est la répétition
je me souviens en 2010 d'une commission
qui avait été créée par les Nations
unies à une COP sur les financements
innovants c'était monsieur Melesse
zenaoui qui était le patron de
l'Éthiopie qui avait présidé cette
mission avec Gordon Brown qui était le
premier ministre et cette commission
avait rendu un rapport en disant oui des
financements innovants bonne idée tiens
on va taxer les transports aériens on
pourrait taxer le transport maritime on
pourrait taxer les émissions de carbone
etc toutes les idées étaient sur la
table toutes les idées étaient sur la
table et là j'entends le président de la
République française dire on va demander
une commission pour faire des
financements innovants donc si vous
voulez
c'est très bien
cette angoissant si vous voulez que on
répète les mêmes choses et que ça
n'avance pas alors on ne va pas discuter
de la réduction des émissions à cette
COP on va discuter d'argent on va voir
si les pays développés et les pays en
voie de développement peuvent se mettre
d'accord sur un mécanisme de solidarité
international je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils
arrivent à cette fois-ci au moins ça
sera mis sur la table ça c'est pas mal
donc ça ça sera nouveau Aurélie trouvée
Greta Thunberg en tout cas elle voit
dans cette coop une opération de
communication elle parle de greenwashing
c'est l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
elle ne s'y rend pas est-ce que c'est le
cas
mais
il y a pas le choix en fait c'est à dire
que c'est aujourd'hui le sol espace
multilatéral qu'il existe sous l'égide
Nations unies pour avancer ensuite c'est
la question de la responsabilité des
pays les plus riches dans cette affaire
puisque ce sont les plus les pays les
plus riches qui depuis 30 ans si je
reprends ça fait 30 ans qu'on a des
coques ça fait les pays les plus riches
qui sont les principaux responsables des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre mais
c'est les pays les plus pauvres qui en
pâtissent le plus donc quel que soit les
efforts à réaliser il faut absolument
les réaliser pour diminuer les gaz à
effet de serre il y a dehors j'ai déjà
une question d'adaptation et pour
s'adapter et ben plus on est pauvre
moins on s'adapte je prends le cas parce
que j'étais prof et à Grenoble pendant
20 ans donc j'ai bossé là dessus je
prends le cas par exemple en Inde un
paysan pauvre et ben il peut pas faire
un forage pour puiser de l'eau et c'est
lui qui empathie et qui va peut-être
demain mourir de la du réchauffement
climatique donc il y a des questions
d'adaptation dans les pays et les
personnes
normalement 100 milliards par an dans
les cops pour s'adapter or on est qu'à
80 milliards et 100 milliards c'est bien
trop peu donc aujourd'hui il y a sur la
table la responsabilité des pays riches
dont la France dont la France parce que
dont la France parce que elles n'ont
plus n'est pas exemplaire en la matière
par exemple elle fait le transforme des
prêts enfin elle compte les prés dans
l'être que nous faisons au pays là donc
y compris la France n'est pas exemplaire
en la matière les pays riches ont une
responsabilité et c'est comme là
permettent aussi de pointer du doigt la
responsabilité des pays voilà on va
revenir sur cette question financière un
beau encore de géopolitique Jean Joseph
Wallo puisque vous êtes un peu le
spécialiste des briques sur ce plateau
les Chinois ont interrompu clairement
les négociations avec les États-Unis sur
cette question climatique on a vu que si
Jinping n'est pas présent n'est
d'ailleurs il ne sera pas présent du
tout tandis que Joe Biden vient lui a
priori le 11 le 11 novembre bon il y a
un froid énorme entre les deux pays ne
se parlent plus laramodin n'y est pas
non plus
[Musique]
moi je ne partage pas ce sentiment
pessimiste je trouve que cette cope27
elle représente un tournant dans cette
longue vous l'avez citée 30 années à peu
près de mise en place du mécanisme mais
bien sûr c'est la démocratie elle prend
du temps et là c'est encore pire c'est
la démocratie à l'échelle mondiale quand
vous regardez
c'est la bonne question s'il n'y avait
pas eu de Coop depuis le début est-ce
que nous en serions aujourd'hui là non
par contre on avance et notamment c'est
la COP des pays africains et eux ils ont
un agenda qui est extrêmement précis
vous avez vu qu'on a inversé ce qui
avait été à Paris l'objet du sablage de
champagne ou on disait oh là là ce qui
est inquiétant c'est la courbe de CO2
c'était ça donc en gros l'adaptation
l'atténuation enfin non l'atténuation
l'adaptation et ensuite on ne parlait
pas des lost de ces fameuses alors non
pourquoi la Chine est l'un ne sont pas
là c'est ça qui est intéressant mais
parce qu'il considère que c'est
l'Afrique qui porte leur agenda en
réalité pourquoi parce que l'Afrique est
dans la situation où était la Chine
finalement il y a 20 ans lorsque la
Chine avait un 30 ans disait mais c'est
pas mon problème moi mon problème c'est
le développement économique et je ne
veux pas aujourd'hui prendre des
engagements de réduction mais regardez
la position de l'Afrique elle est à peu
près là-dessus elle dit écoutez vous
avez pollué la planète il faut nous
indemniser après on va discuter comment
sur quelle base et deuxièmement donc
nous notre agenda c'est le développement
économique Macky Sall arrive avec une
proposition qui est très forte qui est
de dire pas question de de mettre une
croix sur nos réserves de gaz en
particulier comme transition donc la
Chine est l'un ne sont pas là mais leur
ombre est là parce que les pays
africains sa pertinemment qu'ils ont le
puissant Indien et le puissant chinoise
derrière vous êtes d'accord le fait plus
les Américains encore une fois je
reviens sur le fait que Biden c'est une
pink ne se parle plus en ce moment
depuis que Nancy Pelosi est allé à
Taïwan on sait qu'il y a un grand froid
entre les deux pays est-ce que ça va pas
tout freiner c'est évident que si on
veut lutter contre le changement
climatique il faut arrêter la guerre il
faut qu'il y ait des discussions
multilatérales pour arrêter les guerres
pour apaiser les tensions autrement on y
arrivera jamais mais au moins on a une
chose c'est que l'accord de Paris au
moins s'il n'y a pas de d'accord
international de solidarité l'accord de
Paris dit chaque État doit faire quelque
chose chaque État doit avoir sa
politique climatique donc au moins nous
avons quelque chose nous c'est de voir
en France si nous faisons le boulot si
le refait le boulot si les États-Unis
font le boulot donc déjà ça c'est pas
mal ça c'est une grosse avancée par
rapport à ce que c'était il y a 30 ans
mais maintenant au moins faisons cela
vérifiant et pour l'instant ce qu'a dit
gouttérèse c'est que malheureusement il
manque encore un effort il manque alors
travaillons regardez ce qui se passe en
France on passe aux voitures électriques
on a une programmation de l'énergie
alors si jamais assez mais au moins
quelque chose se passe
Marina justement c'est un mot sur les
droits de l'homme trois journalistes
égyptienne ont annoncé en termine une
grève de la fin aujourd'hui pour
demander la libération d'Allah abdelfata
le prisonnier politique britanno
égyptien il est en grève de la fin il y
en a en soixante mille en Egypte des
prisonniers politiques
richissounac le Premier ministre
britannique a dit d'ailleurs qu'il
allait en parler à Sissi quels sont les
réactions de la société civile
égyptienne puisque vous êtes sur place
et bien c'est surtout les ONG qui ont
l'habitude de se déplacer dans ces
peuples la société civile qui fait aussi
vivre ses cops parce que très clairement
il y a toujours les salles plénières qui
se trouvent derrière moi et puis il y a
toujours une autre zone dans les coques
où la société civile les ONG sont très
actives et c'est vrai que ça fait partie
de l'âme de ces coques également qu'il y
ait des manifestations il y a souvent
des sittines il y a de la désobéissance
civile il y a plein de choses qui se
passent dans les Cups chaque année moi
pour les couvrir depuis une dizaine
d'années c'est vrai que c'est ça ça fait
partie entre guillemets du folklore des
cops et ici en Égypte très clairement et
bien les ONG craignent que tout cela
soit réprimé qu'il y ait de la
répression que ça ne soit pas possible
vous parliez de ce mi-temps qui est en
grève de la faim on a entendu sur les
réseaux sociaux que des militants qui
auraient brandi des des pancartes pour
le climat la justice climatique aurait
été assez rapidement arrêté donc c'est
vraiment
ici à Sharm el Sher tout simplement que
la société civile est bien n'est pas de
voix possible Aurélie trouver une
réaction justement est-ce que c'est un
peu une vitrine tout de même pour Sissi
alors que le régime on le sait et
répressif cette Cope ce qui me semble
important de cette s'y rendre tout en
dénonçant les violations des droits
humains en s'y rendant mais ça vaut pas
seulement pour la cop27 ça vaut par
exemple pour la coupe du monde de foot
au Qatar j'attends moi que le plus haut
responsable politique en France
c'est-à-dire le président de la
République en même temps dénonce aussi
voilà les toutes violations des droits
humains dans toute l'expérience
donc voilà je mets mais par contre
j'insiste ça reste un espace le seul
espace que nous avons sous-egi des
Nations Unies pour du multilatéralisme
et nous n'avons pas le choix que du
multilatéralisme à l'échelle
internationale pour résoudre pour
résoudre en tout cas pour tenter de
freiner le réchauffement climatique et
je voudrais juste réagir sur la question
de l'exemplarité et de la France bon le
rapport du GIEC nous dit aujourd'hui
c'est il quelques mois nous dit il faut
transformer profondément nos façons de
produire et de consommer moi ce que je
vois en France c'est quand même qu'on a
un état qui a été condamné par un
tribunal administratif pour inaction
climatique sur 2015-2018 qui ne voilà
qui ne respectait pas les trajectoires
qui aujourd'hui la France et le seul
pays européen le seul à ne pas respecter
les objectifs qu'il s'est fixés en
matière de production d'énergie
renouvelable et aujourd'hui qui vient il
y a quelques jours de repousser un
budget absolument nécessaire dont nous
avions besoin sur la rénovation
thermique des logements et sur le train
donc je dis juste que attention quand on
se rend aussi un sommet comme celui-ci à
être exemplaire parce que c'est
justement les pays riches auxquels on
demande aujourd'hui de faire les
principaux efforts et c'est normal nous
sommes et la France parce que vous dites
non elle n'est pas exemplaire
aujourd'hui dans sa politique là pas du
tout et c'est ce que nous c'est ce que
nous combattons au sein de l'Assemblée
nationale nous avions une majorité lors
de de débats nous avions de majorité
dans l'hémicycle dans le projet de loi
de finances pour voter 12 milliards de
plus sur l'innovation thermique des
logements 3 milliards sur le train 49.3
ou sont passés les amendements que nous
vous demandions et que nous avions voté
à la majorité n'y sont plus donc où elle
est l'exemplarité de la France le salon
l'exemplaire la France ou pas la France
aimait beaucoup moins de gaz à effet de
serre par exemple que l'Allemagne qui a
plus de renouvelables que nous mais ça
c'est à cause d'une nucléaire ou grâce
au nucléaire si vous voulez donc il y a
des gens qui n'aiment pas nucléaire
alors donc ils disent il y a pas assez
renouvelables en fait il faut les deux
quoi donc la France elle exemplaire elle
est exemplaire dans sur son territoire
comme la Suisse comme la Suède parce
qu'elle aimait peu en revanche comme
elle a envoyé ses industries et c'est
ailleurs elle va importer énormément et
ses importations si on les additionne à
nos émissions là du d'un coup on est
plus on n'est plus exemplaire on arrive
au niveau de l'Allemagne on arrive au
niveau de l'Allemagne
80% des Français savent maintenant que
le réchauffement climatique est lié à
une activité humaine contre 65% en 2010
donc là on peut dire que et sur 10
soutiennent le renouvelable 74% sont
favorables à l'obligation faite aux
propriétaires de rénover les logements
et 69% sont favorables à une
augmentation de la taxe carbone si ça ne
pénalise pas les classements moyennes
Jean Joseph boiloya tout de même un
changement aujourd'hui ah mais je reste
assez optimiste dans l'opinion
non seulement sur la France mais sur le
reste du monde moi ce qui me frappe par
exemple puisque je suis là ce titre là
c'est de voir l'énorme chemin qui a été
parcouru par la Chine par l'Inde et et
par l'Afrique en ce moment je reviens du
Sénégal de moi j'étais frappé de voir
que c'est pour ça que c'est important ce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure c'est
conférences internationales ont dit
parfois c'est inutile etc c'est pas la
conférence en elle-même qui est
importante c'est tous les échanges qui
ensuite vont pas ricocher énervés la
société civile et aussi les industriels
parce qu'on voit bien que chez les
industriels il y a aussi la prise de
conscience donc non la question c'est
pour la France c'est pour l'instant elle
nettoie un peu elle pourrait faire mieux
d'accord mais surtout l'air d'accord
à ce qui est quand même l'historique des
émissions à l'échelle mondiale c'est un
peu plus de 50 % les pays riches si on
prend la totalité l'Afrique c'est 3 %
donc ce que disent les africains
notamment ils ont une société civile
aujourd'hui extrêmement active sur le
sujet du climatique quand même et c'est
de dire mais mettez de l'argent sur la
table et je pense que cette conférence
va être importante parce qu'il y a juste
après le G20 si vous voulez vous me
demandiez pourquoi l'Inde
maudit j'ai une prime sont pas là mais
c'est assez simple c'est que là on va
discuter de la facture en gros on va
discuter les gens disent ça suffit votre
objectif de réduction quand on est
président chinois pour la facture c'est
justement il faut que le G20 mette un
chiffre sur la table et je pense que
c'est ça qui va être important c'est la
négociation qui est déjà en cours de
préparation d'après moi les informations
que j'ai des Sherpas du G20 pour dire
voilà le G20 va mettre sur la x
milliards par an par an par an et il est
important de comprendre par exemple le
cas du Pakistan 30 milliards de Lost and
themed liés aux changements climatique
en grande partie pas en totalité quand
même hein la Chine a mis 13 milliards
avec l'Arabie Saoudite pour compenser le
coût de cela donc c'est le G20 qui à mon
sens et c'est là où les géants là les ce
qui vont peser lourd vont effectivement
je pense donner un un amplification à ce
sommet de sa machin ce qui veut dire que
le G20 est plus efficace que la plus
efficace la COP 27 qui est un problème
effectivement parce que le G20 ce sont
les 20 pays considérés comme les plus
dans l'économie et la plus avancée donc
ce sont les principaux pollueurs si le
G20 décide quelque chose évidemment les
autres pays finiront par l'accepter
parce que ce sont les principaux
pollueurs
il faut absolument parce que le G7 comme
le G20 il faut bien rappeler que c'est
les pays plus puissant de la planète il
faut absolument un cadre multilatéral
qui aujourd'hui est celui des Nations
Unies où tous les pays se retrouvent et
puissent y avoir des discussions des
négociations et des accords entre
l'ensemble entre ces 186 pays et moi je
viens du mouvement altermondialiste
voilà vous le savez enfin j'ai et depuis
20 ans et c'est ça qu'on porte dans le
mouvement altermondialiste c'est qu'on
dit mais les choses ne peuvent pas se
régler entre les 7 ou les 20 pays les
plus puissants de la planète il faut que
tous les pays du monde puisse se mettre
autour d'une table et discuter comme ça
des responsabilités des uns et des
autres sous alternes raisonnent pas
comme ça tous ne sont pas pour que vous
fassiez partie des instants etc bien sûr
certains préfèrent être dans la rue et
quand on dit quand on a dit bah quand on
a dit après chacun moi je il y a une
complémentarité des voilà des des je
comprends tout à fait aussi la position
qui est de dire en boycott tout
simplement nous évidemment en tant que
mupestres on s'assumis avec ça on y est
présent parce qu'on considère qu'il est
important que c'est un cadre
multilatéral que nous n'avons que
celui-là Nations Unies et qu'il faut
surtout pas le miner ce cadre là donc
parce que sinon effectivement on laisse
la main au G7 au G20 et et au club au
petit club de des pays les plus
puissants alors on va revenir justement
sur la Chine n'est pas ce surveillance
ou l'Inde pas c'est pas parce que
surveille c'est normal les paysans c'est
très important bien sûr qu'il y a une
des complémentarités mais tout le monde
a bien conscience dans les pays
africains que ce que la Chine met sur la
table c'est uniquement pour des projets
qui l'intéresse elle et que ce que
l'Inde fait en termes de recherche
technologique etc diffuse très très peu
ailleurs donc il y a une importance à
avoir une cop27 avec des petits
excusez-moi je vais reprendre
l'expression les petits ou les grands
extrême dans un pays en voie de
développement depuis 1991 en ce sont on
l'a dit les États les moins responsables
finalement du dérèglement climatique on
va écouter la première ministre de la
Barbade qui a fait un discours très fort
on va écouter aussi Emmanuel Macron qui
s'est exprimé cet après-midi
je n'ai pas besoin de répéter que c'est
la coque qui a besoin d'action
nous tous ensemble lavandi
je n'ai pas besoin de répéter l'horreur
et la dévastation qui ont déferlé sur
cette terre au cours des 12 derniers
mois depuis notre rencontre à Glasgow
qu'il s'agisse des inondations
apocalyptique au Pakistan
des vagues de chaleur de l'Europe à la
Chine ou encore ces derniers jours dans
ma propre région des ravages causés
obélises par la tempête tropicale Lisa
nous n'avons pas besoin de le répéter
car ces images parlent bien plus que
mille mots mais ce que nous devons faire
c'est comprendre pourquoi nous
n'avançons pas plus loin
nous sommes dans le pays qui a bâti des
pyramides nous savons ce que c'est que
d'éliminer l'esclavage de notre
civilisation
nous savons ce que c'est que de pouvoir
trouver un vaccin en deux ans quand une
pandémie nous frappe
cependant la simple volonté politique
qui est nécessaire
non seulement pour venir ici et faire
des promesses mais aussi pour les tenir
et faire la différence dans la vie des
personnes que nous avons la
responsabilité de servir
semble toujours incapable d'être
produites
nous devons continuer le combat de
l'atténuation et que nous devons à la
fois sortir nos économies du charbon
ce qui est au cœur de la stratégie
européenne qui doit être pour le tous
les pays les plus riches mais on doit
aider les émergents à le faire au plus
vite nous avons fait un premier pas
important avec l'Afrique du Sud la
France investira 1 milliard d'euros pour
accompagner cette action sur ce chemin
et donc sortir du charbon et aider
justement l'Afrique du Sud avec une
stratégie qui repose sur le renouvelable
nucléaire les économies d'énergie pour
sortir du charbon Marina vous devez nous
quitter donc juste un mot justement
est-ce qu'il y a une défiance finalement
c'est un peu ce qui transparaissait dans
ce discours de la première ministre de
la Barbade une défiance des pays du Sud
à l'égard des pays du Nord
oui bah il y a clairement deux camps de
toute façon dans ces coques il y a les
pays du Sud vous le disiez qui sont les
plus victimes du réchauffement
climatique et qui contribue le moins par
exemple l'Afrique à hauteur d'environ 4%
seulement et puis et bien il y a les
pays du Nord qui eux ont historiquement
beaucoup contribué et qui sont pointés
du doigt aujourd'hui par les pays du Sud
qui leur disent bien très bien mais
maintenant vous devez payer la facture
typiquement ces inondations au Pakistan
qui sont estimés environ au bas mot à 30
milliards de dollars est-ce qu'on peut
par exemple dire et bien les États-Unis
ont contribuait à hauteur de 30% au
réchauffement climatique au dérèglement
de la planète et bien maintenant ils
doivent payer à temps de pour cent les
inondations au Pakistan et les
conséquences et c'est vraiment ça qui se
passe ici à la Coop et c'est vraiment ça
qui est une source de défiance alors
peut-être que la situation va un peu se
décanter parce que le sujet va être
ouvert je vous le disais tout à l'heure
c'est un sujet tabou mais très
clairement il va falloir qu'à un moment
les pays riches les pays du prennent
leur responsabilité financière et
effectivement adopte un mécanisme où
trouve une façon d'indemniser les pays
qui souffrent de plus en plus du
réchauffement climatique merci Marina
Brice Lalonde justement cette question
des pertes et dommages on disait déjà
depuis le début elle est clé dans cette
coop est-ce qu'elle est devenue une
sorte de ligne rouge c'est-à-dire que
les pays du Sud montent au créneau et
n'importe quel pays mature pays donc
développé qui ne participerait pas à une
forme de financement de ces pays du Sud
serait mis au bon alors pendant très
longtemps cette question a été soulevée
depuis trois ou quatre cops ou 5 Coop
même et c'est la première fois qu'elle
sera que tous les pays ont accepté de la
mettre à l'ordre du jour donc elle sera
discutée il y a une histoire des
négociations on a commencé par réduire
les émissions c'était ça ensuite on a
parlé d'adaptation et maintenant on
parle des pertes c'est dommages mais il
faut quand même il y a une histoire et
il y a une différence puisque
aujourd'hui le pays qui pollue le plus
si je puis dire c'est la Chine tandis
que les pays les pays riches si je puis
dire ils ont commencé à réduire alors
pas assez ça va pas assez vite mais ils
ont commencé le pic des émissions des
pays développés et derrière nous et donc
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire qu'ils sont
moins responsables aujourd'hui dans ce
finance mais ça veut dire simplement que
la la configuration géopolitique du
monde a changé et ça veut dire que la
Russie émet énormément ça veut dire que
la Chine est mais aussi alors la Chine à
la promis que son pic serait en 2060 un
truc comme ça elle est descendue à 2035
2035 donc il faut attendre 2035 pour
voir ensuite il y aura l'Inde ce sera
plus tard et ensuite tu auras l'Afrique
chacun son tour si je puis dire dans la
négociation qu'est-ce qu'il faut il faut
dire à l'Afrique tu as le droit toi
d'utiliser encore des combustibles
fossiles pendant 30 ans ce genre de
négociation là qu'il faudrait qu'il
faudrait avoir et qu'on n'a pas encore
parce que c'est que elle parle d'argent
elle parle de responsabilité elle ne
parle jamais de comment on fait pour
réduire les émissions
juste sur le film ton financement aussi
est-ce que effectivement ce que disait
Marina est-ce qu'on va dire voilà aux
États-Unis bon bah les États-Unis sont
responsables de tel pourcentage du
réchauffement climatique et donc ils
doivent participer à temps pour un des
miser les Pakistanais par exemple
puisqu'il y a eu des inondations
effectivement une méthode je veux juste
réagir sur ce que c'est donc c'est
probable ce type de méthode c'est est-ce
que les questions de ça en fait
aujourd'hui
en tout cas c'est demander par un
certain nombre d'acteurs y compris aussi
des grandes ONG environnementales qui
sont là-dessus c'est à dire
on paye aussi en fonction de sa
responsabilité historique et attention
parce que sur la Chine moi je veux bien
premier pollueur mais enfin si c'est par
habitant nous sommes bien plus polluants
mais c'est important parce que sinon on
peut se reporter en disant la France
c'est comme la Chine
parce que là moi je vais reparler
d'exemplarité attention à ne pas dire
attention c'est la Chine qui pollue plus
en les pays européens une forte
responsabilité j'entends Emmanuel Macron
je suis désolé je réagis quand même à
son discours parce qu'il dit nous devons
sortir du charbon je rappelle puisque je
suis parlementaire national député que
on vient décider dans la loi pouvoir
d'achat cet été de la relance d'une
centrale à charbon de la relance aussi
de la construction de Méthanie gaziers
flottants et c'est et ça excusez-moi
mais c'est un énorme enjeu c'est à dire
la guerre en Ukraine ne doit pas servir
à faire repartir à mort la production
d'énergie elle doit servir à un immense
une immense trajectoire de sobriété
énergétique notamment sur la rénovation
thermique des logements je dis aussi
parce que dans une semaine moi je
présente un projet de loi une
proposition de loi sur la rénovation
thermique de logement notamment avec le
reste à charge Géro excuse-moi c'est un
peu technique pour les ménages modestes
mais on arrive là vraiment au concret
c'est à dire quand un pays dit il faut
faire ci il faut faire ça d'accord mais
chez toi qu'est-ce que tu fais
Jean-Joseph Boileau pour revenir
justement sur ce pourcentage cette
responsabiliser des pays riches
d'ailleurs c'est intéressant de voir le
statut de la Chine comment se fait-il
que la Chine soit toujours considéré
comme un pays du Sud parce que
manifestement je crois que c'est encore
le cas alors qu'elle est en passe de
devenir la première puissance économique
mondiale donc ça peut-être
qu'effectivement ça brouille un peu les
pistes c'est très intéressant ce qui se
passe la Chine laisse aujourd'hui
l'Afrique mettre en avant cet agenda qui
était le sien il y a 20 ans parce que
elle-même n'est plus du tout la Chine il
y a 20 ans elle envisage clairement
maintenant non pas d'abandonner
complètement de charbon mais il faut
voir ce qui s'est passé en Chine
le renouvelable la capacité de
renouvelable représentant Chine
maintenant pas loin de la moitié de la
capacité installée elle a foncé la Chine
pendant que les gens parlent pendant que
ces centrales charbon effectivement on
continuait elle a investi massivement
dans ses renouvelables qu'est-ce qui se
passe passer demain la solution
l'Afrique ça sera les renouvelable bien
sûr non pas parce que le président
Macron
dit une sottise pas du tout il a raison
le charbon même les Africains ont
conscience que bon sur le gars c'est
autre chose attention sur le financement
par exemple la Chine qui n'est plus
vraiment un pays du Sud est-ce qu'elle
pourrait participer aussi dans un
pourcentage par exemple sur les pays du
Sud donc par exemple le Pakistan est-ce
que la Chine pourrait mettre également
au pot alors qu'elle fait partie de ce
Groupe des 77 qui demande eux un
mécanisme financier donc a priori elle
ne participe pas deux choses
premièrement la Chine c'est à peu près
12% des émissions historiques 12% des
États-Unis c'est 25 et l'Europe c'est un
peu plus de 25 donc la Chine est très
loin et c'est son argument et c'est un
argument qui pèse pourquoi parce que
l'un est sur la même longueur d'onde et
parce que l'Afrique est sur la même
longueur
cet argument je ne sais pas par contre
sur la question centrale du financement
la réponse de la Chine est simple la
Chine met énormément d'argent mais elle
ne veut pas participer à des
financements qui passeraient par les
institutions devrait-on Woods pourquoi
et là-dessus il y a un front commun des
pays en développement nous ne
représentons que 15% des droits de vote
dans les institutions de Bretton wood
pourquoi voudriez-vous que je mette de
l'argent par contre que ce que fait la
Chine c'est qu'elle utilise ce besoin de
financement essentiel pour glisser
sa coopération bilatérale c'est-à-dire
PAP et j'ai donné l'exemple du Pakistan
elle vient de mettre à peu près 10
milliards de dollars sur la table sous
forme de prêt etc donc elle met de
l'argent elle allait sur privilégier le
bilatéral finalement dans ses relations
financières la Chine forcément à
l'avantage de celui qui en profite mais
c'est le problème bien sûr les pays sur
cette histoire qu'on comprenne bien
cette histoire de pour cent de
responsabilité puisque vraiment cette
perte cette question de perte et dommage
elle est différente cette fois cette COP
est-ce qu'effectivement les États-Unis
je reviens là-dessus parce qu'il y a des
tas de questions juridiques économiques
qui sont sous-jacentes est-ce qu'on
pourrait dire faire une espèce de règle
disant voilà tel pourcentage tel pays
responsable de financer les inondations
Pakistan tel pays sera responsable de
financer bon là Emmanuel Macron parle
d'un milliard pour l'Afrique du Sud oui
est-ce que lorsqu'il y aura une
catastrophe naturelle enfin naturelle
inévitable en fait c'est ça surtout le
terme n'est-ce pas c'est à dire qu'il ne
peut pas être à l'heure actuelle est-ce
que ça veut dire que là-dessus les pays
maturent les pays donc développé vont
effectivement participer financièrement
quel type de mécanisme qu'on pourrait
mettre en place les pays développés ont
accepté de discuter de cette question
pour la première fois il ne souhaite pas
être considéré comme automatiquement
responsable comme justement devant un
tribunal en revanche ils sont prêts sans
doute à le faire de manière volontaire
et toute la question c'est comment
est-ce qu'il veut qu'ils veulent le
faire de manière volontaire par exemple
les États-Unis viennent de proposer un
système de crédit carbone c'est-à-dire
que si
exactement
répondre à leurs engagements en
finançant la transition dans un pays en
développement par exemple voilà ça fait
partie des propositions qui sont sur la
table greenwashing
largement renseignés par les ONG euh non
mais bien sûr mais il y a une façon d'y
répondre qui peut aussi empirer la
situation quand on demande à des
multinationales comme ça ça peut être
aussi des projets qui peuvent amener à
des accaparementaires vous le savez très
bien c'est tout à fait renseigné qui met
dehors des populations indigènes etc
donc il faut faire très attention aussi
aux mécanismes qui dirait les
multinationales pouvaient polluer autant
que vous voulez vous aurez du crédit
carbone et de la compensation avec des
projets 1 qui sont mal contrôlés vous le
savez et de qui peuvent amener à des
effets délétères notamment sur le plan
social d'éviction population etc donc je
dis attention ensuite aux fausses
solutions mauvaise solution qui
passerait en fait par le tout marché
c'est-à-dire encore une fois un avantage
et multinationales en l'occurrence vous
pouvez proposer en fait si alors ce
mécanisme de Joe Biden il parle
effectivement d'ailleurs d'une
institution d'une instance qui sonne sur
deux juge on sait pas très bien encore
comment ça fonctionne pour vérifier la
validité de ces projets parce que c'est
là où c'est vrai il faut faire attention
que ce ne soit pas de la blague donc il
faut vraiment que ce soit vérifié vous
savez maintenant les crédits carbone il
y en a de plus en plus notamment des
crédits volontaires
une fois que vous faites une réunion
quelque part vous allez dire à des notes
en carbone la preuve je suis allé
planter des arbres je sais pas où bon
donc il y en a donc si vous voulez il
faut vérifier que ce soit sérieux enfin
les deux mécanismes principaux il me
semble c'est un de respecter nos
trajectoires de réduction des gaz à
effet de serre l'Union européenne se
donne moins 55 % de réduction de de 1990
à 2030 et d'ailleurs en France nous
sommes qu'à 40% donc moins 40 % donc il
est temps qu'on s'aligne au moins sur
l'objectif de l'Union européenne c'est
tout voilà tout le monde doit bah pour
l'instant on n'y est pas sur la
trajectoire en France en France on y est
pas on n'est pas sur les points 40% sur
dernières années en tout cas pas d'ici
2030 donc ça c'est une première chose
respecter nos engagements et que les
engagements soient suffisants pour être
en dessous des 1,5 de des plus 1,5
degrés de température dans le monde or
pour l'instant on n'y est pas pour
l'ensemble des promesses de tous les
pays riches et deuxièmement l'adaptation
ce qui est encore autre chose et sur
l'adaptation là c'est un fond commun qui
perd et c'est le mécanisme du père
préjudice qui permet en production des
des de la responsabilité historique sur
30 ans au moins voilà sur le début des
cops au moins en tout cas sur la
responsabilité historique des pays les
plus riches en fonction de l'ampleur de
ses responsabilités qui mettent au pot
commun pour les pays pauvres qui en
pâtissent ressemblent pas et ça me
semble les deux mécanismes principaux
Brice à Londres sur cette question de la
France déjà alors rattraper non mais
déjà il faudrait mettre sur la table les
100 milliards qui étaient prévus depuis
la conférence de Copenhague de 2009
c'est quand même c'est quand même par là
qu'il faudrait commencer
et on en a combien 80 milliards officiel
dans la réalité les estimations qui ont
été faites par des experts techniques
estiment à 50 milliards
vous savez combien ça coûte à l'Inde à
la Chine et à l'Afrique en gros la
transition et 400 milliards de dollars
par an pour chacun pour chacun donc il y
a un gouffre et shamel sec ça va être le
lieu de la donnant-donnant
aujourd'hui je te dis le monde en
développement ce qu'on appelle vous
savez le West Andrest ce que dit le
reste c'est arrêter de nous faire le
chantage à l'augmentation des émissions
de CO2 si vous voulez qu'on a tous au
tronçon on va y aller parce qu'en fait
c'est ça qui se passe par contre si vous
voulez qu'on avance et qu'on crée un jeu
à somme positive il faut désormais
arrêter de parler des engagements etc il
faut parler de l'implémentation vous
avez vu que c'est le mot d'ordre de
cette COP c'est à dire la mise en place
voilà il n'y a pas l'Uranus est un
organisme international qui n'est pas
supranational donc il n'y a pas à
l'échelle du monde un organisme
supranational où on puisse par exemple
dire aux États-Unis vous représenter 25%
des émissions donc donc on fait du
donnant donnant OK et c'est ça qui va
être intéressant vu et c'est vrai que
les émissions continuaient d'augmenter
vu la multiplication des accidents c'est
plus des incidents des accidents
climatiques graves mais aussi dans les
pays riches c'est ça qui est
l'opinion publique a commencé à
gamberger cet été qu'est-ce qu'on va
réussir à trouver en donnant donnant et
c'est pas 100 milliards c'est ridicule
il faut qu'on arrive à peu près à mettre
500 milliards sur la table je rappelle
500 milliards par an je rappelle que la
guerre coûte à peu près selon les
estimations 20 milliards par semaine
donc l'argent est là la question c'est
qui veut et qui veut mettre sur la table
et qui peut contrôler et là-dessus l'ONU
ne fait pas assez bien son travail à mon
sens c'est-à-dire qu'elle n'a pas mis en
place un redevabilité une redevabilité
c'est ce qu'on appelle la redevabilité
voilà ça c'est vraiment le sujet sur
lequel on pourrait avancer qu'est-ce
qu'on appelle la redevabilité et puis
alors justement vous vouliez vous disiez
contrairement Aurélie trouvée que la
France au contraire a rattrapé
c'est ça que vous disiez surtout si vous
voulez que c'est pas la France qui est
le mauvais berger ou le mauvais c'est
pas donc voilà alors maintenant on peut
dire que c'est pas assez mais on peut
pas dire qu'il se passe rien quoi voilà
il y a par exemple moi je donne toujours
l'exemple de l'industrie automobile mais
on ne se rend pas compte de l'incroyable
défi que c'est pour l'industrie
automobile européenne de passer à
l'électrique c'est même quasiment
impossible mais les chinois sont en
avance exactement et donc on risque de
de voir des voitures chinoises à la
place de nos Renault et de nos Peugeot
donc il faut faire très attention donc
c'est très difficile tous les pays
émergents c'est de la voiture chinoise
parce qu'elle coûte 5000 euros pièce
alors que les nôtres sont encore rien
alors justement
ce que je veux dire c'est que la
question n'est pas seulement de
transformer le mode de production il est
surtout de diminuer notre consommation
donc là c'est le transport public c'est
par exemple le train donc là c'est
brièvement le train et oui mais sans
sobriété on y arrivera pas évidemment
qu'il faut de l'efficacité évidemment
qu'il faut de l'énergie renouvelable
mais si à côté il n'y a pas de sobriété
et de diminution de notre consommation
individuelle de chacun en moyenne pas
les plus précaires mais en moyenne on y
arrivera pas simplement la décarbonation
est un effort industriel immense
absolument immense et ça va consommer de
l'énergie parce qu'il va falloir
produire des électrolyseurs il va
falloir produire des batteries il va
falloir les matériaux pour isoler les
maisons c'est un effort et donc
contrairement à ce qu'on croit on va pas
diminuer comme ça la France ne va pas
diminuer doucement sa consommation
d'énergie pour arriver à une situation
formidable elle va être obligée au
contraire d'investir de produire et donc
chacun d'entre nous on fera un effort de
sobriété mais la France tout entière
elle sera obligée malheureusement de
produire davantage est-ce que l'Europe
va continuer à être leader ou va-t-elle
retrouver son positionnement de leader
parce qu'il me semble qu'elle l'avait
perdu justement à cette cop27 comme
exemple non elle est elle est
manifestement le continent qui fait le
plus d'efforts pour pour cette
énergétique oui 55% en 2030 c'est un
effort immense donc elle le fait en
revanche elle a perdu ses atouts
industriels elle va acheter en Chine
elle ne sait plus construire des
batteries etc donc l'effort que fait la
l'Europe en terme de réduction des
émissions doit s'accompagner d'un effort
industriel immense et c'est trop tard ah
non rien
n'est jamais trop tard
optimiste et parce que je ne suis plus
finalement si jeune si jeune que ça par
contre je vois j'étais prof jusqu'à il y
a trois mois j'ai eu des étudiants je
peux vous dire à la gourde Paris je peux
vous dire quand je vois les étudiants
quand je vois tous ces jeunes étudiants
pas étudiants qui se mobilise pour le
climat moi j'ai un espoir y compris
toutes les actions désobéissance civiles
qui sont en train voilà qui se
multiplient parce que les jeunes en même
temps ont peur mais en même temps
agissent et ils se disent on peut pas en
rester là et moi c'est cette ces
mouvements partout dans le monde
notamment de la jeune génération je sais
pas moi j'ai des enfants j'ai mal
peut-être vous aussi mais moi je vois
que c'est quelque chose qui en même
temps les angoisses et en même temps les
mobilisent et c'est ça moi qui me donne
l'espoir
émergents on ne regarde pas c'est ce qui
se passe dans ces pays-là dans les 9
personnalités
civiles se soient mobilisés que vous
ayez des innovations de de de notamment
des innovations frugales comme on dit on
parle pas assez mais le domaine agricole
vous savez c'est le tir des émissions
n'est-ce pas
écologique vous avez le même type
d'espoir les jeunes oui à condition que
ce ne soit pas inspiré par le désespoir
est-ce qu'il faut c'est l'espoir et il
faut que les jeunes aient confiance
parce que la transition c'est aussi
absolument passionnant c'est un monde à
construire donc c'est passionnant merci
beaucoup Bruce Leon d'avoir été avec
nous merci Jean Joseph Boileau merci
Aurélie trouver merci Marina Marina
Berthe qui était avec nous donc en
direct de Charmed cher en Égypte merci à
vous tous de nous avoir suivis vous
restez avec nous sur France 24